I want my son to be happy I feel it's a
bit unsafe it's a sobering image
a mother and her two-year-old son
homeless what's happening they group all
of us together people with mental health
and people who drink and do drugs and
stuff and then you've got us moms you
know and we don't really have a choice
we've got to be here
this is their temporary accommodation
they've been here for months I've got a
thing at night time and stuff if it's
safe and you know I normally lock my
door with my buggy up against it just as
that extra protection
Nicole fled domestic abuse she works
full-time but still needs housing
allowance but that doesn't cover rent
she makes this two-hour Journey daily to
her son's Child Care can I get on the
back please in a place she's struggling
to find an affordable rental in or that
will take on a single mother I've worked
since I was 17 I've dedicated my life to
working so why am I finding it so
difficult it's a little unfair but
I just in the back of my head I say to
myself you know you keep fighting
eventually you'll find somewhere or
you'll get something and it will be
worth it are you okay I know you're
doing everything for Logan but are you
okay
I mean I'm tired I'm very tired and I
just put my son's needs before mine
new figures given exclusively to Sky
News show the gap between housing
allowance and the actual cost of private
rent has risen by 40 in just five months
people in two bed homes now have to find
another 1500 pounds extra a year above
what they get in housing benefit overall
affordable homes for those on housing
allowance have declined by more than a
third leaving just eight percent of
properties within budget this isn't a
sort of
um a prediction of things getting worse
it already is worse we know that rough
sleeping is going up we know that
councils have nowhere to put people and
unless in the November financial
statement the government increases
housing benefit in line with inflation
just like they're talking about for
other benefits this is this is going to
be catastrophic
but this is a is a situation years in
the making
same reasons a lack of social housing
pushing people into the private sector a
lack of private rentals pushing up
prices and that's down to low stock and
longer less now all of this has got
worse in the last few months because of
inflation mortgage rate Rises and the
cost of living crisis and that last
compounding Factor the fact that housing
allowance has been frozen for nearly
three years
the government point to a range of extra
support available but no mention of
raising housing allowance and local
authorities are stretched councils need
more resources in terms of being able to
fund homelessness services and to
recruit the necessary number of housing
officers
to to provide that support
it's a housing rental and cost of living
crisis all wrapped up in one with a
potential homelessness emergency for the
poorest just around the corner Adele
Robinson Sky News London